العالم يترقب عاصفه ترامب بعد غد الثلاثاء
ومدينه نيويورك مشاهدينا التي توصف
بالعاصمه الثقافيه والاقتصاديه للعالم
تتاهب امنيا وتضع سته وثلاثين الف شرطي
و19 الف عنصر مدني قبيله مثول الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب اذا امام
المحكمه لابلاغه بتوجيه التهم الجنائيه
اليه في قضيه دفع اموال لنجمه افلام
اباحيه لشراء صمتها محيط المحكمه تحول الى
نقطه شبه مغلقه والفريق الامني والمكلف
بحمايه ترامب ينسق مع السلطات عمليه
الوصول الى قاعه المحكمه والطرق التي
سيسلكها قادما من برج ترامب حيث سيبيت
ليلته فيه بعد وصوله من فلوريدا اما
العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن فتتحضر امنيا
ايضا لمواجهه العاصفه السياسيه رغم دخول
الكونجرس بمجلسيها الشيوخ والنواب في عطله
لمده اسبوعين بمناسبه عيد الفصح هذا
المشهد مشاهدينا يبعث برساله مروعه للعالم
تتعلق بالانتقام اكثر مما تتعلق بالعداله
كما يقول الحزب الجمهوري على لساني نائب
الرئيس الامريكي السابق
سفيره الولايات المتحده السابقه في الامم
المتحده التي اعلنت رسميا ترشحها للفوز
بترشيح حزبها لانتخابات
2024 الامر ابعد من ذلك ايضا توجيه
الاتهام من شانه تصميم السباق القادم الى
البيت الابيض تقول صحيفه تايمز البريطانيه
التي اعتبرت ان محاكمه ترامب تشكل سابقه
يحتمل ان تكون خطره للرؤساء المتقاعدين
بمن فيهم الرئيس جو بايدن الذي قد يجد
نفسه ضحيه لتصفيه حسابات قانونيه ايضا
وبالنسبه لترامب ستكون المخاطر شديده ولن
تقتصر على حريته فحسب بل مصيره السياسي
الذي بات على المحك لكن المعركه السياسيه
مشاهدينا التي اندلعت بعد لائحه الاتهام
ضد ترامب ست ختبر اخلاص واشنطن لمبدا
العداله والقانون بمعنى انه لا يوجد احد
فوق القانون تختم صحيفه التايمز
[موسيقى]